as our population grows and more people
choose to walk and cycle we need to
ensure our networks are safe and connect
people to where they need to go
last year we asked you where you think
we should be putting walking and cycling
connections and what areas we should
prioritize when building this network
building a route connecting kaiapoi
through to the Ravenswood was a clear
priority as was connecting the passenger
path safely through tirangi order
the council has secured Government
funding to build these routes and now we
want to share our plans with the
community
to find out more about what we have
planned pop into one of the drop-in
sessions where you can talk to one of
the team
if you missed the drop in sessions just
jump online and tell us what you think
at
waimakaditi.govt.nz forward slash let's
talk we'd love to hear from you